se faire enterrer ou se faire incinérer
voilà des pratiques qui pourraient être
appelées à disparaître pourquoi parce
que ces polluants et qu'il existe des
solutions de rechange plus écologiques
comme le compostage de corps humain
[Musique]
plusieurs études suggèrent que la
crémation émet autour de 200 kg de CO2
que l'inhumation dans un cercueil est au
moins trois fois plus polluante au final
mourir c'est l'équivalent d'un
aller-retour Montréal Paris en avion
la Suède est six États américains ont
légalisé le compostage de corps humain
aussi appelé humusation selon ses
promoteurs au lieu d'émettre des
émissions de CO2 l'utilisation
permettrait de séquestrer une demi
tonnes de carbone
cette vida les propriétaires d'un des
quatre établissements américains qui
offrent le service
[Musique]
le processus rappelle le compostage fait
à la maison le corps est déposé dans une
boîte appelée un vaisseau puis
transformer en humus grâce à des
accélérateurs naturels de décomposition
copeaux de bois foin luzerne et mélange
bactérien les familles peuvent aussi
ajouter des fleurs ou des lettres
d'amour sur du papier bio dégradable une
fois le vaisseau fermé la température
est maintenue à 55 degrés Celsius
pendant 3 jours le but éliminer les
agents pathogènes le processus peut
prendre de deux à quatre mois au final
les os sont broyés et les prothèses sont
retirées et recyclés à terme on produira
1 mètre cube de terreau noir sans caveau
ni en mouvement ni gaz
selon la juridiction il y a des règles à
respecter en général on doit tester le
terreau pour s'assurer qu'il n'y a pas
de traces de bactéries et de médicaments
dans certains états comme au Colorado il
est interdit de vendre le terreau ou de
l'épandre sur des terres en culture mais
on peut en disposer sur n'importe quelle
terre privée en France on vient de
déposer une proposition de loi pour que
les élus puissent en débattre une
démarche qui peut intéresser beaucoup de
Français
qui sont à la fois
soucieux
d'une démarche on va dire presque
philosophique de la façon dont il se
projette après leur mort et il y a une
dimension aussi écologique au Québec des
consultations sont en cours mais chose
certaine il y a de l'intérêt on
s'intéresse aux compostage humains en
essayant d'aller chercher le plus
d'informations possibles parce que c'est
une technique qui amène le développement
durable c'est une valeur qui est propre
aux coopérative funéraires
et combien coûte tout ça aux États-Unis
environ le même prix que l'inhumation
si Elisa serrer Radio-Canada Montréal